the Joe Rogan experience you moving it
while I was trying to read it don't do
that bro that's rude [ __ ] up that dude's
name tied to Eve us as an animal those
are that's a great [ __ ] fight that
guy's crazy
that's that guy that drinks out of his
shoe you ever see him do that he does
shoe ease He pours beer into shoes and
other people's shoes he'll I tell
someone to take the shoes off he pours
beer into their shoes and drinks it oh
my god it's so disgusting yeah it's so
foul yeah I don't get it but I get it I
don't get it but I get it he likes to
party he's like that dude in Talladega
Nights what the [ __ ] his name the
other john c reilly yeah john c rise
like a hearty party party it likes to
drink out of shoes [ __ ] it he's an
animal I guess like I mean if you want a
really show you don't give a [ __ ] that's
a good way to go about doing it just
grab a man's shoe and pour a beer into
it and drink it
his dirty sweaty feet have been funking
around Matt have you died from that
imagine if someone's foot fungus was so
disgusting that even the alcohol didn't
kill it and it germinated inside your
gut where foot fungus is never gonna be
like if if there's venereal diseases all
right we all know there are because you
dirty [ __ ] like what what are you guys
doing to each other you're both giving
each other dirty [ __ ] things with
dirty things and like diseases are weird
right people give each other disease
this venereal diseases which are extra
weird it's like oh you dirty people
you gave each other's dirty dirty
diseases but nature says we don't like
this nature just lets these sneaky
little parasites and viruses and
bacteria getting your body what if there
was an even more powerful one for people
who sucked on feet what if it got in
your gut nature's like this guy's just
too much of a freak we got a column
column for the herd it's like if there
was foot sucking diseases you know
before you make out with someone you
gotta tell them hey I just want you know
I got a foot sucking disease so if you
don't maybe we shouldn't do this
what Jamie what are you making faces for
says you can get staff from doing this
of course you can science confirms
Chuy's are really freaking dangerous
especially if you're rich why is it more
dangerous
that's clicky I try to get us with a
clicky bait you can get yeah you can get
staff don't do it yeah I don't study to
figure that out yeah because because the
staff aurorus can cause toxins and these
cox toxins are quite resistant to heat
they they're quite resistant to the
acidic environment when they can survive
protein breaking enzymes out Jesus
Christ if you drink from someone's shoe
containing staff and its toxins yes it
can give you an acute gastrointestinal
[ __ ] all that since but alcohol is a
disinfectant right well yes but there's
always still a risk of infection
especially if you have lower ABV alcohol
by volume drinks as you'd expect higher
ABV drinks like vodka do a much better
job of arak eradicating bacteria so yeah
beer which is what they drank which is a
low alcohol beer or low alcohol beverage
what a [ __ ] up way to die done you got
to do shots and those things shots are
fine oh my god people are crazy but no
one's happy with like taking it and
leaving it where it is everybody wants
to take it to the next level you know
like everyone constantly like you want
to one-up somebody I'm gonna drink out
of your underwear bro I'm these your
underwear as a [ __ ] filter no and
dude you're gonna be do undies they're
just gonna be ripping each other's
underwear off and using them over a
filter put it over a glass and drink
right through your underwear